даша курей не ding встигаючи за для своєї
софіст на кіл про україну в дні з
карибських кальярі
дитинча організував облаву діну акцій
УЗД збору кішки для армії вручені
держава
додати волонтери ті допомоги та девід
серце
доходи читку то не знака і в колінах
бюрократії вкажіть активісти
рік тому даша протестувала на майдані і
там вона познайомилася з Віталієм зараз
вин на фронті
його звуть дебра на допомогу
волонтери особливий ставить возять солдатам
спочатку шлях до дійду маріуполя
даша всю не трохи дорожча вона знаючи між
папір волонтери в батах ліктем на
фронті чималі вони ще вони води вони
теплого про біг на русі за зустрічі Віталія
23 rock & win студент історичного
факультету ці дашин один за майданом
солдати розмножують про вичитав про душу
відмінювання пічку телевізор цирк це
медикаменти отрути зчитує і батальйони
обіграти цю повну припасу солдати
розбився та польові tabbert у одному з
сільських дворик нападали на вуха
артилерія даша привезла українську
прапор
і попросила солдатик написати та послання
вона хоче кілька дотацій про бурхливо на
ступні активі збору коштів для 5
солдати упевнень всю провину йому нав'язав
і здається og відриву ти ми є російська
агресія геть із віце на підуть у режим
крипи мене в кутку хлоп тиною вірити
абсолютно не вірю і не думаю серця і на
не так скоро закінчилася як би нам
хотілося цьому чим вона вигідна і
одні inci сторони koln та я пара нині eмy
віриш вивчай на так сам він йому чому
чистий на солдаті минулий трин біля ванілі та
у лобів шансу
виталий кузьмін кука ж там існує дубаю
краще ніжний ендо я за своєю натурою але
за своєю природою демократ там у розділяючи
now see цінність цих організацій
організації поділяю на годину для мене
важливі ви їх не патріотизм
ви не були в менше гарячих точках до
воювала росія
он і давала їм бачиш vepa видно
виймаєте тему повний доз або він ей досвід
для відстані
далі подружка та на
еньші big фронту проте для українців
життя мального у групи мандрі вко
завершується
їм долину можна продовжують роботу
позбавленням етики екологи віку пряму в
glee психи дно та україни до луганська
страхуєте блок порожні і ки доводите
проїжджали лотків витрачає ілек
аеропорт луганська
щоб рис не всю територію вид був і
як вони самі себе називають
борці за нову росію тут даси
противитися першому чому аеропорт нас
тільки страти особисто важливі ви
пояс її один із тих хто тут воював
безумовно відновлюватимемо тому
що безмовно буду мій вигляд вдова ти боже
тя це здається не запилилась а й у нас
по переду валики плани та волоки завдання та
китає муканова ти любиш ще у нас на
сьогодні вже єни вали пелетний склад
вже у дим чи так готові до роботи вже
один літак готовий до роботи
квитки днів я пам'ятника ленину попелюшкою
одні їй побут ви ланцюг боротьбу вольськ
одна з на біржі рунованих боїв і nist
до вини тут проживало і 38 тисяч людей
переважно противника та шахт the fabric
втратила близько половини населення
одні кажуть українська армія їх так
покарала
і жебрак і шановний burti за нову росію
окопи волосся у житлових кварталах
викликаю china себе у вогонь нафти ліли та
2 місяці civile коріння
карим листя місцям прийняв і на собою
донські козаки
разів субота 7 з тур німецькі журналісти
дозволяють краще усу проводі влаштованого
наочна комендант і мають рацію чи то місця
і в гані та цуценяті робіть хлібом і кричить
років левит крив я долею якоба тих місць їх
мішкан секрету та вид голодну смерть йому
козака убори немає та м'язи луганську бойових
льодові приватний пропускав і сюди
російський гуманітарний конвой
мені вже підлозі у пенсію ми не в дупі в
руку на дає від яви машина забу дику
погоди погані тієї суди є і тут буду
ходити сюди їсти комендант за store
гаючи пенсіонерку на раз побачити на
камеру щоб допоможуть так на ціла
один український олігарх
літнє цуценя отримуєте з раулю млинець батько
їх козаків андрей пушкін ніжно ложки
собаку сусідньому та право травневому
стаханові винза владним і слова ми ж
за виглядом я за збрую щось внутрішній без
пеку командувати козацьким полкам
розбавляючи російську без українську
акценту кожен що гвинт весну не тут
народу і вся, а ви всю землю і лудить уже
ставити нацистів і годину-другу святого і
провини за землі дуже близькі вони тебе
земля ту ж близьку до нас вони
Просто іншому цьому я тут то
моя 3 травня в руках збрую цьому все
державним один з томів путчу досі 6
якщо звір на неї території новоросії
звільненню території на баросі
доки одні виділяються своїх прав через і
жебраку сядь у чикаго ти сам гавкаю
шляхом у банку риф першотравень у бабусі
матері 1 очка біти uuid я ваш на вигляд
хіля Валентина Василівна втратила б
зітхну і блакитний місяць тому ракета
вручила у гізі but enough
але я думаю ненависний я думаю таку
ненависть між людьми може вибити
равликів та пусети ми в сажі важкі
українці russian і ось тут на донбасі
я тут всю життя прожила і на те ж
одному і папірець не в нас не було манії
здається
жадібною на вас темі здається ніякою
он і за ручно kevin і
ЗМІ села не ослабла не забудьте